foreign
item one apologies for absence
thank you councilor bushby will be
leaving at 10 30 hopefully returning it
will still be core at Boston
item two the minutes of the community
and resources Committee of the fourth
third of the 24th of October Pages four
to eight
um I'm gonna read from the bottom
page four
but
that's a little knock yeah 275 the
forward plank out of the brother asked
why the plow was no longer on the
forward plan but I understand now that
the player has been awarded 125 000
pounds per annum for the next three
years so is there any reason to keep it
on the floor plan
[Music]
who's going to answer that one okay
Steve hi
um yeah there is a reason uh this
committee administrator be put on the
forward plan when the previous report
was approved last year so that was a
recommendation from this committee
um back in I think it was September 21.
members decide to take it off the board
one because they just need to come
forward so that's um
back to members of the committee
thank you do you feel it needs to be on
the uh
guaranteed 125 000 per annum for the
next three years which is more than ever
it's original in
yeah
actually I'm encouraged to give the
money if actually you put them in a
better position to go and get a grant
funding that's kind of the reason they
got that funding the birthplace and we
gave them money previously
that we can stop doing that that may
affect the ground availability later
before you still be considered
yes Steve there's nothing in the budget
to suggest we will continue making uh
contributions to below the the minute if
I recall correctly was that we just
bring back a report to review the
business plan uh a year after the
decision was made to put a one-off grant
to them which I think was ten thousand
pounds
um in last year
well I'm taking on board what kind of
bright has said so I mean I would like
it to affect them not getting any
further bro so perhaps leave it on them
okay
we'll move on page
and five
uh I haven't yet seen the telephone
directory
in a minute 279 I hope that it's
progressing
I'll chase that with my TV channel
page six page seven
page
eight if you're happy that those minutes
in effect are a true and correct record
can we please show our counselor James
you're proposing yeah
um
is there a second death
sort of lock
are we all happy with them please show
thank you I think that no we need to
count
one two three four five six seven eight
those against
those abstaining
warranty nine that's about right than
that
okay
item three the action list page nine
any comments or thoughts
thank you
I think they're complete all done and
all in a position to be deleted them
so I think uh 281 chair the uh cashier
Christian group raised that had asked
that that remained on the forward plan
because it's something he wanted to
travel
um
right
but we can just leave it to him at 6 80.
[Music]
okay do we need to vote on that no
right
item four
public contributions
unless we have some right
who have we got
um
right good morning can you hear me all
right
thank you right my name is Phil Clark
and I said absolutely thank you
all right firstly introduce myself uh my
name is Phil ploke I'm I'm the chair of
great torrington's planning committee at
present
uh firstly
I am somewhat surprised that we're
having this meeting this morning
I've got no doubt that the development
company are fully aware that the correct
protocol and procedures for the naming
of new developments
therefore I wonder at best whether their
actions show a certain amount of
forgetfulness on their part or it was a
disregard for following correct
procedures
secondly I find it disappointing in
which way the way in which a small part
of our community has been involved in
this process
by making the naming of the development
the a competition on the developers
Facebook
[Music]
uh Facebook to the page
offering the price of namely development
was something which had not had been
done I'm sure that the developers
however are in a strong position to both
explain the errors of the ways and to
compensate the disappointed winner
should you the committee decide that the
main Market Garden should not be given
to the new development on South Streets
but incidentally this name was actually
put as the winning name on Facebook on
July the 23rd which was six weeks
approximately before the developers
consulted with ourselves with a
suggestion of the name and I believe
slightly before they commented with
yourselves
thirdly the name Market Gardens although
having a distant and historical
relevance to this part of the town is no
longer a program neither a garden or a
market is within close proximity of the
new development and we as a council fear
that it may distract and confuse people
from visiting our own garden or in fact
our own Market which is the new revived
and vibrant pannier Market
bothly as a council we've put forward
the names Queen's view this being a name
which clearly reflects the desire of our
community to have a permanent and
fitting and Lasting remembrance made to
our great and Lane Queen Elizabeth II
is it interesting to note that the
developers in response to this on the
25th of October said there is already a
street in Torrington called Elizabeth
Court
honoring the late Queen I say
interesting because at the time of
Elizabeth Court opening uh our hog
Majesty was still very much alive
therefore I wonder why this was said
and finally I sincerely hope that
lessons will be learned from this
morning's meeting and that parties will
adhere to correct protocol and
procedures in the future
or if such policies are ignored and
individuals and organizations are
allowed to do as they please surely many
problems will arise
thank you for your time and your
consideration
thank you for the way it was broken
thank you very much
right
we will come to that in
a minute well yes fairly soon
item five the forward plan page 10.
any comments
no
right we'll drive along
item six Declarations of Interest you're
all experience counselors I don't have
to explain that one I'm sure but we just
bring to your attention of the need to
declare if you have one
item Seven Agreement of the agenda
between Arts one and two
there are two items put for
suggested as part two one of them will
be hard in part one and then get to a
stage where it'll have to be deferred
into part two the other one will be a
straight into part two
that's our guess are you happy with that
suggestion
James
all in favor please show
that is
no I've got a cam I can't see counselor
yeah
[Music]
oh she's not on the committee ah
yeah
eight yeah
okay
um
so we move on to item eight urgent
matters I've got nothing
[Music]
I'm not going to juggle with the agenda
a little bit because
to his credit cancel the Council of Ford
has been up half the night running
around delivering newspapers we'd like
to get home and go to bed and as the
Apple door member he has requested that
he can speak on item 16.
so I've said that we'll deal with the
part one part of item 16 now which will
give Council report his opportunities
so
uh
you're gonna take this matter
um
then I'll let you have a go after that
all right good morning everybody
um just a quick introduction for those
of you who weren't there because I
haven't uh presented before uh Nick
Argos the um interim State manager
um so the
um
restaurant proposal at appledore fish
stock uh before you
um the main purpose is to consider the
conversion of the upstairs floor of
building a the main building at the fish
stock which is currently a net knock and
storage area uh into a seafood
restaurant
um and this has been proposed by uh Tony
Radford who I'm sure is all uh well
named to you he is the principal at
least holder at the fish dock uh his
current uh the rent we currently
received from him is about three
quarters of the rental income his least
actually expired in July this year so he
is effectively holding over we haven't
had any negotiations on a new lease
whilst this proposal um is uh is is
being is being discussed
um so
the reason this has come to the four
again is that we initiated from the
Estates team compensation with him as a
result of his police expiring and he
said yes you'd be interested in
discussing with us but you really wanted
to discuss the wrestle proposal in in
detail so we completed a meeting with
the with the tenants uh in in mid-july
where Tony presented his uh his
proposals
um and there were some fairly uh Lively
discussions around the pros and cons of
that
um uh and I think the the main idea is
that he would convert the the netloft
and the storage room into a restaurant
there will be a balcony which would take
advantage of the wonderful views uh
there would be a lift installed to allow
for disabled access
um and it would primarily be open at
lunchtime sorry not at lunch time it
would have been even wrestling not at
lunch time so that it wouldn't
compromise the work stock which is
predominantly operating during during
the day the main concern at that meeting
was that he was looking at building a
new building to the key side of building
a where most of the tenants have storage
and on occasion boats are lifted out so
it suggested that there was space in
Building B where the uh the ice machine
is and other tenants operators of uh
where you can perhaps convert the
mezzanine to provide the requisite next
net lot of storage and other storage
there and dispense with the need for his
proposed new building and his architect
went away and worked up some drawings
and we had a further meeting in
mid-october
um now most of the tenants actually
didn't attend because it was a good day
so they all took the opportunity to go
into scenes obviously that's the most
important aspect keep their businesses
running but they they had previously
been asked to submit their their
thoughts anonymously
um and and it showed that in in in
principle they were they could
understand Tony's Ambitions he he's
obviously not getting any younger and
you know he's unlikely to carry on in in
the fishing business per se and so this
is him trying to explain that it was
diversification and ensuring the
longevity of the overall fish stock
um the some of the reservations were
that uh the the needs of the fishermen
were not compromised
um in any way uh because I think they
understood that if Tony was to have a
lease it was possible that he would have
a lease on the whole of the fish stock
and he would become the de facto manager
of the fish stock and so they would
effectively all be his tenants and they
were I think clearly concerned that he
would be able to dictate whether their
leases were renewed or when their rents
were increased beyond the market rent
but we we were able to reassure that
obviously TDC would have a a strong
control and and a managing input going
forward
um they said that they would like to see
the the first Forum building be fitted
uh fitted out before the escort proposal
was enacted for obvious reasons
um and there were concerns around
whether the restaurant could operate in
conjunction with uh the fish dock
obviously you've got the public going
into the restaurant it is a working fish
dock
um so parking is an issue which we
believe could can be resolved and a
couple of times pointed out that access
is required 24 hours a day so they would
have to be some physical separation but
but we felt that those situations
couldn't be managed
um uh anyway
um
the site isn't managed as I'm sure
you're all aware and anyone who exists
that the fish stock it is recently it's
very obvious that it isn't managed and
uh we'll get the facilities manager our
facilities manager devote some time uh
that there isn't sufficient resource
within TBC
um to provide full-time Management
Services uh I believe a character has
been tried before but that isn't that
hasn't been successful and so as I said
part of these things proposes that he
would take at least on the whole
um and would effectively take on the
management responsibility
[Music]
um
there are obviously they're all
obviously be quite a lot of legal work
to get everything set up but uh legal
um safeguards could be put in place to
ensure the tenants livelihood and their
businesses going forward
um the financial implications that that
Tony says that no there's no uh
Financial uh cost to TDC it would be
through his his own his own money
um it would probably uh save quite a lot
of management time for TDC officers
going forwards
um
and it would also hopefully provide a
reduction in the maintenance cost and
time that TDC officers currently
currently put in
um
so I think uh and then also he was
pointed out that the restaurant would
create local jobs
um they'd see he believes it's a good
fit for the the growth of the area with
middle dock
um coming on the screen in a few years
time and the general increase in the
residential developments in the area as
well and it would be new it would be
something different for the area and the
USP or being able to eat your fish that
have been caught and processed
immediately immediately balloon
um so uh the idea just just to summarize
the the position today in in the hopes
that it can be discussed and if approved
the next stage would be to save Stone
rather than right you can now go ahead
and submit your planning application
which would also see tease out and a lot
of the issues that uh the fisherman have
raised uh as as well so I think that's
my my summary of the situation
um well to discussion and questions I
imagine yeah thank you any questions
first of the officer
no
[Music]
learning right
um councilman Ford I'm going to have you
next oh cancel that Ames you won't speak
You're a board member action of that
yeah thank you
um yeah I was just can you clarifies
um yeah can you clarify there's the
handing over the tenancy to the Mr
brother because that's would that be
separate from the restaurant idea
um we haven't had any discussions around
um the tendency would work would we we
envisage that if the restaurant proposal
goes through his committee and goes
through planning uh at that stage we
would then enter into lease negotiations
with him and part of the idea would be
to Grant at least to him uh on the whole
of the bishop so they would effectively
be done simultaneously it is it isn't
given but that's what we will do so if
there was a strong rejection or members
here or even planning said uh we agree
with the idea the respawn proposal but
we would rather that he has given a
lease for the restaurant alone then we
would need to look at another solution
for the overall about Facebook and the
management of the fish dog so that's not
set in stone yet
thanks chair I'm sure you've given me
this opportunity
um
I don't think there's anything I'm going
to say that actually does need to be in
part two but it's just a number of
overview
um I have uh call your meeting with uh
its own corny and spelled out some of
the things I'm going to say no
um because I did pick up on something
that the officer said I'm not going to
go his report he's dealt with what he
could you know and what was put in front
of him and whatever but he did say
principal police Elder he's not the only
one you know I don't want to go over
overgrown councils but we have art
issues in the past so I and I'm just
going to Loosely say I don't want this
to end up in many Kibbles or it's a lot
of legal work involved I'm not being
critical because you can do whatever you
like this site after about my penis not
a problem and if I come back in two
years and said I told you so it won't
really give me any I'm just going to the
local lab my concerns
um so that's you know it's it does need
to initially that and don't actually I
totally previous one actually because it
is a mess to be fair right and I do
signifies the council's position on that
be fair
um
if you could answer a question right
away any officer please do so or I would
like an answer and write them within a
week if possible I know we're all busy
okay so let's try to keep it as simple
as possible what I would like to know
was any councilors involved in the two
or three meetings that has taken place
before at all okay
have we done or where are we gonna do
are we going to do a proper and bear in
mind we might almost be received as
biased and it's a proper environment
impact statement
again I did a lewd and probably say this
because it's all public knowledge and I
don't need a part two on this I don't
want us to end up even though it would
still be our greatest day I don't want
to end up with a Glover case scenario I
alluded to that and cancer can ask you
to get uh to expand on that
I'd also like and pleased to understand
I've taken this out serious but also
because of my nature I do try to be a
bit jovial
I'll simply say from my perspective I
wouldn't really want to have um
to dine out of Market Steakhouse outside
of abattoir and see me little well you
know Aberdeen Angus going in when I
ended no one other at his brother or a
sister but this is my perspective
um
again it's been alluded to it's
important
grab me if I'm wrong but I think we have
13 times a week anybody can unless
unless you're actually over at the Isle
of Wight okay so they do actually
operate at night time
do you really want to see people coming
in like I do on occasion Effingham
blinding because I've got an old day or
a bad day and fishing yeah that's what
you're going to see
um
God bless them
um also with this I've been alluded to
any any attempt to go forward with this
it was predominantly and it is which
I've been always supportive of by the
way and I've had the same views as I did
alluding you could not do it in support
Sean I actually said if my brother was
applying for this I'd also had the same
concerns okay but West ashore not for
against any personalities I'm just I
just stopped into six like but it is
something needs to happen and I haven't
got the answer to that so I do
understand why you've looked at it
um The Loft would have to be built first
because we've always had that on other
plan applications nothing happens
also
a sweeping statement tips all the down
boxes oh it's going to employ this
something about who the hell do anybody
in this room actually know that and do
you know as a result what other business
is it going to show because I'm going to
make a prediction
I actually think we got enough
retail outlet and apple know what's
around the corner and I feel I really
feel for any business owner and Apple at
the moment I really how do you do
because you'll invested interests I've
got chair is yeah I drink too much and
all all of the establishments I'm doing
my best to keep on going all right but
I've said you wanted to leave I ain't
gonna do that because one man only is
only just one man but I'll try to be bad
now it's great about the shipyard and I
mean that but I'm really good bit of
news recently and I actually find a
general manager to be a very honorable
Straight Talk and Club we'll be honest I
got no actually at all he's doing a
great job down there but going back to
the governor scenario I just going to
tell you that a shipyard doesn't operate
with rubber hammers all right West
assured
right now this is me again please just
it's only because I'm trying to be witty
it's a serious issue but it appears to
me this could have almost been dreamed
up at the 19th Hole when the world
doesn't go for to be honest after 10
points but let's just where I'm coming
from I want to make sure there's no
subling
because I know I've I've not been
included in this which I find disgrace
and I've been like I've been ignored all
the time because people don't like
learning for if he speaks the truth I'll
get over that I can live with that I'm a
bloody war member and I won't use that
word don't you forget it so I want no
subling otherwise it's gonna be eight to
his old chunk I know these Chums is very
good because what I'd like to say was
the leadership star what experience has
the applicant actually had in the
restaurant trade none by on admission
like site visit I would suggest actually
because you're in principal today you're
going to change the changing you you're
a queen single life that's basically
what I'm asking you to do I actually
think this committee at this stage
should go down there and see what you're
actually talking about because I
wouldn't stick my nose in I've said this
before I won't go with don't know who's
worthy and tell you what to do or even
Dan winkley I don't know
so I think that would be an opportunity
now basically I want this answered
actually have we got hostel
accommodation right there by the road
I can answer all of your questions in
the state yeah and if you buy it they
don't know as well actually because it
won't get that there's a lot going on
down there
and I keep saying I'm not here to rip
you're a part or anybody you just gotta
make decisions on facts not fiction
and with that I think I've given you
enough to think about I'm gonna have a
laugh or I forget my course next listen
to the point that I'm getting forward
there's one question very heavy in my
mind
how many fishermen are there in apple
door at the moment both on part-time
right you've got is that question isn't
quite straightforward what you should be
asking is no money is actually using
that site all right well they aren't
exactly the same all right so I'm not
ducking it
you're probably talking and I'll leave
it in space yes another fisherman I'm
alluded to this because I've actually
talked and listen it's actually you
might open after this my old man I
didn't get on with it but he took he's a
young lad he needs you know why you got
two years and one man because you know
they're bloody listens voice as much as
you talk and very often I don't follow
that rule I apologize but I try my best
I've gone and I've listened and actually
a lot of them say exactly what Sean you
said it's not being managed
okay I can use that word it's a message
like wait what I normally saying
um and his issue is I ain't got the
outside I'm very good sad at coming here
and being negative I would have rather
have been included earlier on so I don't
have to come here and be negative I
really do I'm not always negative at all
but after that it's probably only about
six bolts I reckon I reckon I could
actually come back to you which I'm
quite happy to do as well within 24s and
list of all of them because that's your
point which is ask why this applications
come forward and I agree with that
they're asking a downturn last year I've
got that problem It Ain't Easy for the
applicant it's not actually it's not
well before this is actually serious I
wish I hadn't won mate I haven't got the
answer and I apologize for being
negative but at the moment I'm just
saying ready for it
as cancer are learning forward at the
moment would not support any change
abuse for another arrest form in Apple
at the moment
because what's around the corner it's
not looking pretty
and just remember you get 10 jobs here
you might lose 30 down there
we're in bad times we all know that I'm
spelling of the obvious I wish it I wish
it was happier days chair
if they'd been suggested to me that
there's only one full-time vote going on
there is but there's more other people
use that facility that's your point
where are they coming from well benefit
box or maybe even but there is other
people using it it's actually not quite
right about that apple or just two I
don't want to split errors you're right
it's not always subscribe but what I'm
getting that
do you want any fishing to keep going at
all because it is difficult at the
moment and there is issues with the site
big ones it was big ones and you know as
for you I'm not going to fall open any
of that you do what overnight you have a
nice restaurant there if you like I'm
not gonna fall right I'll still speak to
all of you even though you don't want to
speak to me not a problem I'm a man I'm
a gentleman
okay thank you uh councilor lock yeah
just one one I'd like to bring into
accounts and forms of tension
um I was in Abu door and went to vote
yesterday and I did make it my business
and drive up to and into the Hitchcock
so I have been no thank you for that
because that's what you should be doing
mate and thank you very much for that
appreciate it and I love you Olivia all
right
sure before County support goes I can
respond to his three points
um in terms of member consultation other
than our meeting last week There's a
many specific all member consultation
there has been a presentation to
property and projects working group and
that's where the sort of mandates to do
to work up the scheme to get to this
point has come from and we've also
discussed it with casual Hicks as part
of our his League member role for
property the important environmental
impact assessment no not none done yet
but I expect there need to be some
consideration on that around the
planning application and that would be
the next phase that these proposals
should they be approved and hostile
accommodation not yet so you just as a
council approved uh planning permission
for hostile accommodation in the
Harborstone Cottages that hasn't been
implemented yet but it is the Cancer's
intention to pass yeah and then I just
like the honestly because everybody just
needs to pull back so I didn't like to
say it's your job and I'll still be
happy happy no matter what you decide
you know I don't have to make the
decision I'm glad about that actually
it's easy for me to come everywhere to
go I don't really wish to be but you
know I'm rather be positive but and
something needs to happen to the site
the goggles what are you gonna do with
it
but thanks for your time okay children
I'm good yeah
um right we can now move on I've got
counselor lock oh no
laws looking to speak I'm sorry I thank
you chair
um and does Sean have any information on
um fishing boats that actually discharge
their cash there from out of the area
for instance when we get a control we're
in from the world does it discharge them
because the whole thing seems to me I
mean
what the Liverpool says oh imagine the
smell in the restaurant so it are the
considerable numbers in the discharges
there or is it literally just the one or
two that being told
uh chair I mean I I can answer part of
that Nick might chip in because uh he's
been having these discussions with with
Tony Rutherford so my understanding of
it is that as it's been spoken there
aren't that many uh trawlers operating
out of capital and so Landings are
limited
um the processing facility doesn't just
operate on fish landed by applicable
traumas other traumas sometimes allow
their catch there but that isn't hugely
frequent uh but what does happen is at
times where there's we're not able to
catch your specific species aren't
available locally or whatever
um he does buy fish from other fish
markets and they're transported by roads
to the site and processed in the
conservatives thank you okay
okay
yes cancer Himes yes thank you
I should say something I haven't
actually been poorly Consulting yet I
don't think but so I know I've had
information I might just share our own
Council of boards
reservation is so obviously don't be
positive but wishing wishing the
gentleman luck and uh sympathizing with
his needs and you know to make his
business and flourish
um do have reservations about the
location of the site and I think a lot
of that will come down to the planning
application and what's what's being
proposed
um I do think picking up the Council of
Paul's points about a visit to this
committee I do think it's very important
that people do go and visit bishop and
have a look and see what's being
proposed
um and I'm not sure well I hope this
isn't Part B but I think there should be
a full business case presented really
[Music]
um
which sort of does actually give
everybody the figures and
um forecasts and budgets and everything
for the proposed
pension and I think that's highly
important as well
thanks very much
councilor Brenton thank you chair I'm an
associate this there's a two issues here
is no personally there's the the
planning application which has to be
dealt with Bible planning and that's
that's it but the other one which I
think is more significant and that is
the uh future of fishing or or at the
present time I think off machine
industry is in an absolute state of flux
thanks to the brexit and other factors
as well you've got a question mark over
hail question mark over bricksome you
know it's there's no security in the
future and here we are we have a
facility here which is actually owned by
the taxpayer local Authority and we
should guard that jealousy that future
we should not generalize it in any way
at all so I if the two can marry
together that's not a problem I don't
see the business of somebody you're
saying about it or I think Mr Coast
report they'd say about you know mixing
um the industry of Landing fish with
actually eating the product afterwards
when on that basis then the Venice
patient Market should have ruined the
entire restaurant business in and around
that area and it certainly has not done
that quite in Reverse so I don't think
that's a problem either if you go down
there for a meal in such a place that
you have to expect
but that whatever happens we do need to
have a report back to this committee and
this committee will this Council we
decide how it is a future pans out and I
do think we owe it to the next
Generations we don't know what's
happening in the future there's always
going to be a market profession the
price is rising all the time so you know
it's a is it from a sales point of view
it's a healthy future of that respect
and there aren't that number of ports
around where you can land and fish so
we need to bear that in mind
councilor Hudson
uh uh like councilor Brenton I quite
agree with him about uh the market for
fish in Venice but we we don't have to
go so far if you go to any coastal town
in Norfolk uh East down there
um they often have fish being landed and
the small restaurant bars or pop-ups
serving the fish people go to
restaurants and shoot those who are
operating up I'm not claiming to have
done this but choose their lobster uh
that are swimming around in the tent so
I think it I think the abattoir and cows
was a little extreme I think we're we
have a different attitude towards fish I
don't think any competition is healthy
this isn't going to be a Vast restaurant
it's going to be open in the evenings
for people to have a different
experience they're going to have to find
it whereas the uh restaurants in Apple
door themselves are in a very prominent
position so they will
succeed or fail on their reputation for
their culinary skills
my concern is not about smells and fish
and the right is about the leases now I
am concerned about this because there
seem to be in the presentation we had
some uh misgivings about the
restaurateur becoming the main
leaseholder and uh I think we need to be
very careful about that and make sure
that we consult appropriately with the
existing leaseholders we heard the main
the applicant uh Solis has actually run
her own at the leases for the other
fisherman run out as well
were they all concurrent were they all
running at the same time and where
exactly do we stand those are the
questions I need answered not whether or
not we have a fish restaurant
uh no the other leases have not have not
run out
um they're not uh they're not
co-terminous leases that they run out at
uh at different times we could provide a
detective of these uh at least these
stories should you work
well thank you I think that puts another
issue about when we're determining these
leases
um and which way we should go forward
but I would be
um
one full and open consultation with the
existing leaseholders as to their
feelings about becoming uh tenants of
the mainly a mainly solvent
councilor bright thank you sir uh yeah I
mean this evening I'll definitely go
there uh is it in the right location I'm
not quite so sure I mean it's not an
easy place to get to really and I'm
wondering about parking because well
there's a car mechanics garage well it's
very triple block pretty much all the
time
um where would people actually Park if
they go into this radical it's probably
a later consideration
um
[Music]
is you know somewhere more because you
know
uh
um we need to make sure that he is
accountable and you know he is just
doing what yeah it was just suggestive
and he's just giving it to his mate
Compares other people they can't come
you know if that thing kind of thing
goes on we need to protect against it we
make sure it's Gotta Have you found in
that as well
um you know because I shouldn't any
disagree and take place we don't want to
threaten the rest of the efficient
industry we've got that
right
councilor James all right thank you
chair I've actually been to the site uh
we then went in the new ice chicken
machines installed which was done to
enhance the the uh what could be done
there with terms of fish because the old
nice to make the machines went to the
different committee but actually
damaging the fish so we've done that the
place is a bit of a mess I think we
would agree that the fishermen are not
particularly looking after where they
stole stuff it's also driven their Nets
or fixing Road and all sorts of stuff
all just stepped on the end of the day
um of course downstairs there is both
the processing and the retargeting of
the fish so there's already a shot there
I don't know there are several people
working in it there it must have been
four release so obviously there is a
turnover for directly Supply the fish
I would hope and I would expect it to
enhance the area personally I've got
concerns about the lease but that is
found equal to Palmer if they've got any
concerns to come back to us and say this
is an issue at the moment there's none
being packed up but as Nick said that
some of the um the agreements went over
different times and having one person
doing all that is a little bit worrying
to me I think we need to save God
but if there's only one boat actually
got there uh I don't know whether does
he actually control the processing stuff
as well Mr Rutherford yeah yes he does
yes
everything that's going on on that side
other than a bit of Landing is actually
under the control of one individual uh
chair the there are a couple of other
people on the site down there Nick's
probably better to answer this I think
uh down the Fishman operates from the
site doesn't he he's got his own retail
business I'm not quite sure how he saw
some speech where he sort of saturation
I don't know
um there's a man that does bait of
course when Chris Leonard uh he operates
from the site and he's got some other
activity down there as well isn't he
foreign
[Music]
busy so
yeah that works and I've spent another
Paces you know I don't see why you
shouldn't work you know so I'm quite
happy to support it subject to some work
on the reasons
pencil a lot yeah I mean as I said I
went there yesterday
um and there were two Transit bands
there for various other parts of Devon
but on as you drive in on the right hand
side it was just a mass of old fish
boxes and I'm sure that they were all
there there'd be a lot more space
um and I know several people that visit
the fresh fish shop when you know and
they're really pleased with it and I'm
sure that the restaurant will be used
so you know if it was all at the least I
think that the way forward when you
think how many
um other restaurants that might close
temporary or for good and this this
gentleman prepared to open up a new one
I think it's easy to be supported
right well looking at this the
recommendation on page 114 I have a gut
feeling that we can look at that
recommendation and vote on it without
going into part two in fact
uh if anyone would like to propose that
Chancellor James councilor Brentwood
seconds
those in favor please show
I think that is unanimous isn't it
thank you
right
thank you
we can now get back on to the agenda as
printed
and we'll take item nine the new
development of Southbury Park
[Music]
um you will have uh you have noticed
with all the extensive guidance and
policy and procedure documentation that
we already straightening and numbering
Authority uh we've received an
application for new development of South
Street car park in Torrington from
Pierce construction they would like to
call the development Market Gardens as
part of the consultation process we
obviously consult with the Town Council
and the guidance says that the County
Council don't agree and they suggest
other things that needs to be agreed
with the applicant and then the name can
be set but it seems to be continuing
disagreement here and that's about to
come back to you 2009 Council would
prefer that the development was called
either Queen's view Royal view or Royal
Square for the reasons mentioned by Mr
cloak earlier on okay I say is
construction but disagreed with that
we've had two Ward member consultations
returned on this one catch the bright
and councilor cotton honkin both in
favor of Market Gardens
um but it's over to you the choices
Available to You chair are that you go
with one or the other option or you come
up with a name of your own thank you
hello there we are take your pick folks
who's a good counselor Blake knowing
priorities just declared interest
because I've talked to town councilor as
well but you see my opinion the
difference maybe
um but I just wondering uh why is it
allowed that
we can suggest names and the apparent
agreed rather than saying the local
authorities of the evil one or it
decides because I'll be the ones
designing our area not the developer
absolutely that's why it's with you
today uh disagreement between the
applicant and the Town Council you you
are the street naming and numbering
Authority and that's where the projects
can be used for a decision
but but if it didn't come to us it would
be down to the applicant the side if
he'd agreed with the Chinese yes
given them the control over whether
they're accepting it or not rather than
a local authority to decide
that's the that's the policy we have
adopted that's procedures we have yet
well thinking about it logically if you
were a developer Building 100 new houses
in the Town Council wanted to call it
the shambles it wouldn't be very happy
would you
um right other comments please or
somebody make a proposal
our proposed Market whichever it was
okay guys yeah
second are for Market Gardens yes I have
one
have I got a proposal for something
Royal
yes I have have I got a second there
another vote
those in favor oh councilor Hudson sorry
but we don't call it Royal Market album
[Music]
um
specifically recorded Queen's new in
memory of the late Queen uh the other
two were at times who had minutes under
discussion but for the last planning
meeting it was unanimous that a council
wanted to call it Queen's here
it does raise the question in my mind
that you'd go up to Scotland and
remember there's one place they call it
Queensville where Queen Victoria used to
like to go and spot as Queen Elizabeth
ever been to this sport
I don't understand it I very much guys
in but bearing in mind the actual views
are probably one of the best Majestic
views within the town and we've received
pity and bearing in mind and assuming
recently that we've lost our Master
Stephen green but haven't seen the thing
and as I think I tried to emphasize
earlier it has the way the development
company has gone ahead they're
completely ignores the protocol that you
yourselves
right cancel the leather
thank you chair well I'm not a member of
this community but I was very interested
in reading this and to listen to the
town council member from great
Torrington
and as a support of our parish and town
councils whatever Parish in town
canceled what was kind of street name
and goes should carry the day in my view
and I used to live at more lodgy under
that area have we ever got called Adam's
court is beyond me because that used to
be how the Road Plantation where we
lived and Adam called it Plantation
court that Adam sport goodness knows
that came from but the principle of
stream them and if the local Council
can't agree with the developer the local
Council needed for me should always
carry the day
thank you Chad
I agree okay our counselor only one more
Council that is just stated that
Plantation wherever was it this was a
Market Garden at one time so surely it
follows might be governments follows
argument okay is that right yeah I I
just think yeah we should be just going
back to the developer and kind of just
reaffirm that they shouldn't be making
promises they can't keep about naming
them if they try to do this kind of you
know competition again and then you know
try and you know going around the same
process again and again you know they
should be all told that actually it's
not there the problem is away okay I
just wanted to affirm the point you are
the street naming and numbering
Authority it is your decision what this
uh development and any other new
development is called
um so they can run a competition to seek
guidance on a name there's no fault in
that uh they can award it but it would
be seemed to be a little bit um ahead of
the curve doing that because actually
it's your decision
proposals
those in favor of Market Gardens please
show
one two three four five
those in favor of Queen's view or
similar please show
one two three
there it is a chair
sorry talking to me
okay thank you very much for your time
um I honestly think that you might have
been up a box of Dorsey because if
developments continue in the way that we
have been treated I came to imagine what
names might be coming forward uh it has
turned vertical in something and
therefore I'm very very disappointed
thank you
right now we move on items
DDC carbon footprint
so yeah
and I am Donna on the climate officer
for person that could not let me perform
um so this is a paper that Jan put
together
um just to report on the carbon
footprint for the period first of April
2021 to 31st March 2022 and and just
reports that the total footprint for
that year was 4 267 tons
is that better than him now yes so the
total footprint for that period was 4
267 tons carbon dioxide equivalent is
that that includes things like movement
and other relations
um
and
um
yeah recommendations that that result be
noted and that the report provides a
basis for understanding and discussion
for members on our way home
right you've all had the opportunity of
reading it
who's wishing to speak first
that Chancellor dark my apologies let me
enrichment
tempting
no I've just um observed in a report
there going forward we appear to be
compromised between finance and doing
the right thing and in essence
the Crux of it is if there isn't enough
money I can't see how that we can do the
right thing so
um and it's not just us as a council
this was true throughout the nation
um what's the options
I don't know the answers they don't have
any answers we're all in the same boat
aren't we
that's a harsh reality
I mean I guess it depends on what
happens with the Net Zero by 2050 UK
government Target because if that is
serious and what UK government wants to
achieve they are going to have to come
up with some way of fundedness and
they're going to have to come up with
ways of funding the work that the
council wants to do
but we are in very difficult times and
I'm not seeing at the moment that those
discussions are happening at you know
cabinet levels so yeah we are in a
really difficult position with this
um
I have no answers I have no Magic Pot
money unfortunately or the magic wands
that people would like to
um you know to to sort yeah I don't know
what the answer is but I think
we have to keep looking there are some
pots of money available to do property
improvements that the council could
potentially take advantage of and and I
think uh Nick and Adrian and I have
spoken about that and and being in a
position where it's doing some projects
that would take advantage of that
funding properties in a small part but
it would be at least a second in the
right direction and I know Richard host
is so
always looking at Waste and Recycling
and what you consume to improve there
but again it's very heavy
councilor Brandon hey Jack uh well I
know you know Financial restrictions
mean that we're limited to what we can
do as an authority we're saying with our
own properties however are we working in
partnership with the county or anyone
else to to look at the packages of uh
installation
Etc to uh panels of typical of the
general public to partake in but I say
this because of just come back to
Hampshire and they are actually doing
um packages if you like for householders
you know where somebody will come along
and assess your potential for solar
panels eat exchange pumps that type of
thing and then there we're putting in
bids with the these contractors so
they're very competitive to allow the
public or you know householders rather
to take advantage of a much better
environment in terms of doing things for
their own properties are we doing
anything like that or have you got any
Partnerships at all in that respect so
we work with Dunham County Council and
and yeah there are various
government-funded schemes available
groups of public but I don't think and
this is sorry this is Jan's area of
expertise so I'm not 100 sure but as far
as I know we're not doing anything
specifically separate to the
government-funded sleepers with the
County Council or with other local
authorities but there is a meeting
tomorrow afternoon that I'm going to so
I can try and find out for you right so
I don't see anything in the local press
about us being involved in anything
which is on the health the householders
reduce their energy bills we do quite a
bit but we tend to direct it through 361
Community energy so yeah right
councilman James
um
comprehensive report from when we've
discussed it before we've got twins head
we have all the information there's an
awful lot of information there they're
not Baseline that we can use to go
forward
um sort of in that respect I welcome the
report I'm pretty supportive secondly
take another case Advantage right on
forever getting phone calls from firms
offering to come and uh you know
insulate the hosts which we've done
quite a lot and my only question is is
but then we should be looking at
how we make sure some of these are
really are not taken on viable uh
vulnerable people and just pushing stuff
through you know there was a bit of a
thing a couple years ago a bit more now
where there was some work being carried
out that was really just turn up say
they've been there and take the money
from the government will never supported
schools so I'd love them that we did
have some thought
[Music]
I just wonder whether it's a bad witch
if we were staying for some or whether
it's a genuine some of the ones were
getting or Genuine skills but I do
welcome to the poll a lot of work I know
the Leisure centers and that better then
and now I understand why
um but there wasn't bits there yeah
we've got some information
okay one sort of hangs uh yeah I just
like to the brush on her work and hard
work and comparing all this data for it
it does that counts so James says it
provides the basis for us to move
forward I do realize that there is
financial implications for this Council
but
spreading to the um you know climate and
finance come together in a way that we
put a future of energy and security and
energy crisis it makes sense for this
Council to invest in Renewables and its
own property with that in order to
reduce costs so you know that's the
other two tied together
they called
um grasp all the opportunities for
funding from from government and other
sources I mean it's hard as the county
there as there was a scheme but the
buying is so approaching the system I'm
not quite sure what happened to that but
I never said that County sort of
what comes up with a further initiatives
like that which we can take you know we
can party
from the chair I just sort of Wonder
we've had
our climate committee now on this
Council for nearly four years
I just wonder what they've actually
achieved when I see
2021 20 to 21 figures being exceeded by
2122
you know has it just been a talking shop
what have they achieved
who's extremely active in doing the
basic work that she's just reported to
the point is that we have to find a base
and get the data together to do the
carton assessments for appointments
transport Etc in order to move forward
and now that is the vital work which
dollar has done
um so that was what I suppose a large
part of what climate committee has been
doing over here as well as looking into
all sorts of other possibilities where
we've been engaged with a community at
workshops etc etc but basically it's
getting this data together so that we
can we know what we need to do
that's very important work
councilor Hobson sorry and and it was
before me I think all right well it just
seems to me that
um you know that every step forward you
take in terms of combating
um climate change in any small way
you know as Richard has put in this
report or somebody put in on which
behalf you know yes the the new Depot
would really enhance our our greenness
however that then brings on more
challenges as in we can then collect
more waste and that actually negates the
the benefits so every step forward you
take then you tend to take one back
and you know
there's always a very up there's a death
and it's a bit disappointing and and in
terms of the 2021 21 22 figures you know
the Baseline you started with Donna
was not a real year was it you know
we're in the company yeah yeah so the
Baseline was actually a complete
misnomer so you may as well just
disregard that year completely and take
the 21 22 or whenever we all started
getting back to normal as reality
I mean it just I mean it's a really good
report but
I don't want to be negative but what's
the worth of it frankly you know it's a
lot of time and energy gone into this
report that seems to be throwing out the
window
Hudson first right I I quite agree with
uh councilor Dart that you took the
words from my mouth about me not being a
real year for an assessment because of
the pandemic but the other point I'd
like to make is
don't let's just look at these figures
and go oh well let's look at them and
make sure we're joining them up to other
agendas we've just had a presentation
regarding apple or fish stock and I know
from the indirect Emissions on page 56
the Albertville fishdom from A and B
actually exceed the emissions from uh
Riverboat house
so if we are doing something let us make
sure we put the measures in place
when we're looking at a planning
application to reduce those
significantly and have a real impact on
our figures and I'd like to see us
looking at those things when we're
looking at our making sure we're taking
all the information we've got and using
it to influence the future and
improvements in our indirect emissions
and achieving some of these things it's
going to be difficult but if we just
go on without taking these figures into
consideration we're not going to achieve
anything so really good piece of work
but let's use it as a foundation for
influencing other decisions that come
within this Council
thank you
counselor laws
and we asked Richard Hayes
uh what he would do if he was a
challenge you might have to do something
now because this is a situation we're in
the world is in
that should we be asking Richard should
we be going to one monthly rubbish
collections carbine the imaginative of
vehicles traveling all over our huge
area burning burning fuel if it's
possible other areas have gone to three
weeks
we could lead the way I know it will be
unpopular but being popular isn't what
we're about here is it
that's Neil as this could mention to
Richard and see and see whether he
thinks he's ridiculous or whether we
could pop down on the deal with them
thank you Jen
and so Richard is acutely aware that he
has quite a big contributions to
council's carbon footprint and and we've
got we've got some free consultancy
through the energy saving stress
specifically looking at our Fleet
operations and how we decarbonize those
thinking about that 2013 target at the
council set and my understanding for
talking to the people at the Energy
savings trust is that they will look at
all of the options which would include
um you know not only using
vehicles with different fuels but they'd
also look at
changes to collection but it's none of
it is uh mandatory it's they're just
doing as a consultancy exercise for us
to come up with some options
thank you
well councilor bright oh yeah I just
wonder
um because obviously our industrial kind
of areas are these Setters you know for
the environment section people look at
the solar panels on the roof to try and
mitigate their things or do we go for
like a green group where you you know
fans it up instead I don't know which is
more effective uh and the same with the
fish stock you know is we're looking at
a possible kind of application coming
forward you know so animals on top of
there or
[Music]
um maybe publicized in that and say that
this is a you know good practice for
businesses to go forward in the
industrial sector because there's so
many buildings out there I mean look at
that and they said if others are on
those routes completely wasted States
you could easily put them on and you you
know you could generate your own
electricity trying to make some some
money you know it'll all help but it's a
lot of Western space just out our window
foreign
[Music]
yeah I mean I think that's going to be
discussed later on isn't it but um yes
my understanding is that renewable
energy is one of the options that
they're looking at on the environment
Center but the council has to decide
and we have got solar panels on this
building and there is some solar on one
of the Apple door blocks thinking about
the energy survey Nick there is a little
bit but not very much but yes when you
look out of the window this industrial
is saying there's a huge amount of
wasted roof space that we can put
noodles on
uh counselor law yeah I mean I know you
know whenever we have planning
applications
um in and the
um developers are encouraged
um to put the solar panels on new builds
and even solar pumps and things like
that so if you can start from the
beginning with new houses that would
also help
yeah uh with regard to the environment
Center there will be a full report
coming in next meeting the meeting after
all the cats anyway
[Music]
been to bear in mind many of the groups
have been there for a number of years
and wouldn't support the weight
of celery angles so the cost of
improving the actual structure maybe too
much to bear for the people involved as
well as the cost of installing solar
panels
yeah
okay absolutely
thank you chair well this Council and
it's a legend Collective wisdom signed
up to an unattainable Target of
so-called zero carbon by 2030. there is
no such thing actually as zero carbon
things like opposite things one of the
biggest problems going but to look at
what's in the report here and I looked
at some of it uh yesterday afternoon
before my eyes glazed over how to stop
um all the things we're doing in my
Northern Town Council are doing things
like cycle racks and things I mean the
Hilton's it's just a coke at the moment
it's like the new religion and some
people sound up to him and believe it
and others like a name for a very very
skeptical I couldn't tell for them it's
just an unachievable yoga
don't worry about it
all right well there we are it's a
report for noting I think we've clearly
noted it and discussed it though from
that position I think we moved on to the
next item
which is
uh
item 11 energy survey report summary
Pages 59 to 63.
so sorry it's me again can you can you
hear me okay cool
um so uh we have had energy surveys done
of all of the torridge properties
[Music]
um
the the the the big ones who've not done
all the
um toilets and things like that and
apart from the three Leisure centers
because when we started doing them they
weren't part of our property portfolio
and apart from some business units in
holsworthy that are vacant and failing
that you can see anyways so I can't let
them out it's not gone tenants
um and also another business unit in
Hull City that's got sensitive Medical
Care going on in the building and it
just it wasn't it was a bit complicated
to to try and arrange the energy survey
so we've we've we're not going to do it
um basically we have appendix one that
gives a summary of the findings for each
of the different buildings and there are
quite a few buildings where solar has
been recommended to be looked at
um including increasing solar generation
at Riverside and Riverbank
and again
um there are significant opportunities
for the council to reduce its energy use
and obviously at the moment that's going
to save money and it will also reduce
our carbon footprint but um you know
some of these uh measures are low or low
cost but then there are a number that
are going to need funding and that will
have to come back to the right committee
for that decision to be made
so um again the recommendation is that
the committee notes the potential energy
efficiency measures possible
and that you agree that these are
reviewed and incorporated into our asset
and management strategy and within the
action delivery plan that has been
developed
councilor Hurley thank you on page 60
um table they're talking about payback
for years
as based on the local price of 15
Pentacles and that's well at the date
isn't it it is well updated but
unfortunately all of the reports that I
had that had energy saving that had the
facts and figures
were various ones and there isn't there
isn't anything up to date that I could
find and it's certainly not in in my
past experience so that's that's why I
made that note because it is out of date
and those those figures will be wrong
but that's the best guess that I can
give you at the moment I'm not
criticizing that what I'm saying is the
biggest there the payback times will be
vastly reduced they will be because of
the cost of more than double that now
yeah so then we'll come down so the
table now
at the time it was correct but now it's
misleading yes I just yeah no you're
absolutely right it's not they would be
that the payback would be less but I
haven't I can't quantify that at the
moment
Chancellor dark I was just going to say
actually leads and alcohol
um
um but it appears to me that if you
produce energy at the moment you really
want to store it because selling it back
to the grid is absolutely a waste of
money
um the problem is getting hold of
batteries
I think they're in really limited Supply
I don't know whether cancer Haynes knows
everything more about that but certainly
um within the building trade
um the word on the street is actually
you can't get batteries for love and
money and some installations aren't
going ahead because there isn't the
availability of equipment
um so actually there is an issue there
um but I would want to see us storing
our own energy and using it because
certainly at home we've got solar panels
and we sell it to the grid for
absolutely peanuts and yet we're buying
it back and the whole thing is in
absolute nonsense I'm trying to get
battery in quite a phenomenal people at
the moment and there are a lot of money
as well so
um yeah going forward I think that's
that's got to be the way to go surely
yes if we could generate our own energy
and store it yeah be a significant
benefits yeah
pencil Ames yes take out the point that
that Warsaw is still I'm not sure the
world battery shortage
um that northern town house or we
managed to actually obtain batteries to
score our solar levels
but I know that it's um Richard hates
it's our trouble sourcing batteries for
uh
uh cordless equipment on the estate
and uh so you had to go over to some of
it how to go over to an apostle Bill to
petrol powered equipment it's just
another example we're going to step back
which councilor data is referred to
unfortunately but um we have to keep
trying I think the problem probably is
China where you know the home impact for
anything
producing what they can which maybe is
an argument for this country to invest
in battery because it seems to be
bailing so much at the moment but so we
hope that things improve
foreign
[Music]
Asset Management strategy and so um I'd
like to propose this recommendation
these recommendations
anyone right will put it to the vote
those in favor please show
one two three four five six seven
those Against One
that's it
[Music]
foreign
should be fairly quick delegated Market
approval
chair on the agenda is so Prince's
gender is a number 12 and which is just
a verbal update from the beginning of
governance on
um
yeah
my apologies
[Music]
number 12.
it's all right
so before the meeting was circulated a
flow chart and just as an age Memoir
um I was asked to give an update on when
storage has a duty to home people
um obviously because
um homelessness has been at the
Forefront of many organizations and and
we've
um spent a lot this year on temporary
accommodation
[Music]
um but effectively
um our duties in relation to housing are
are extensive
um I'll just start with the flow chart
to the left
um prevention Duty
um so this was a firmer Duty that was
introduced onto origin 2017 but
effectively
um we need to provide assistance to
anyone regardless of their circumstances
if they are threatened with homelessness
now I say provide assistance that that
may be advice
um assistance it doesn't necessarily
extend to Homeland homing
uh people
um unless
um our further duties in the middle
um kick in but anyone's entitled to
appoint us and legally we have to
provide that assistance now you'll see
in the book the fourth box down it says
about a personal housing plan and that
effectively is means the housing team
having to do an assessment of a person's
needs
um what type of accommodation they would
need
um uh it also might mean entering to
negotiations with their current housing
provider
um to try and prevent them becoming
homeless in the first place
um we would do that anyway and we do
that as as one of the male
um because obviously to prevent the
eviction or homelessness
um is preferable
um both of the families
um and for torrage
um but under ordinary circumstances when
someone approaches us uh for housing
um it comes down to the box at the top
um uh whether they have a local
connection and and broadly speaking
under the legislation and people have a
local connection to torridge because of
I'm residing within the torridge area
being employed within the torrage area
and have family associations are in the
torrage area or because of other special
circumstances
um special circumstances maybe because
they've had to come to this area fleeing
uh domestic violence
um but it is is quite a gray area and
there are other circumstances when when
we would assist
um so then we go to have they been
threatened with homelessness within 56
days
um are they likely to lose their
accommodation
um by losing their accommodation it
means they've got no legal right to
occupy any other property
um being practiced and with homelessness
I think we've all seen in the the news
recently
um that the subsection 21 notices to in
fact they're called no fault evictions
um and that essentially
um gives them two months notice in which
they have to vacate that property and
it's at that stage that the team will
start to work with people will start to
negotiate with landlords
um predominantly to try and keep them in
that accommodation
um if not they move on to being homeless
so the the first box is do they have a
local connection to storage if they have
a local connection to storage then we're
under a GT if they don't and they have a
little connection to another area then
obviously we would refer them back to
that Council
um then do we have a reason to believe
that they're in priority need and
priority need would be families of
children and people with disabilities
um people with severe health conditions
for example or someone classed as
vulnerable
um it also
um extends to care leavers under the age
of 20 within the torridge area
um so if they're not in priority need
our homeless doesn't kick in and we
wouldn't be offering them temporary
accommodation if they are
um they take that box of being in
priority need being homeless and having
a connection to storage then that's when
we have a legal Duty or a statutory duty
to place them in temporary accommodation
should we not be able to find
um permanent accommodation for them at
that stage
um whilst they're in the temporary
accommodation
um that's when we've continued working
with them to find suitable
um permanent accommodation and we'd bear
a personal housing plan
um housing plan predominantly at this
stage um what their family need is if
they have children
um if they have disabled access
requirements
um but really the Crux of the matter at
the moment is affordability we have we
have a legal duty to find accommodation
that is Affordable and that's the
difficulty that the officers have been
experiencing at this moment in time
because often we're finding rents just
aren't unaffordable for them and that is
predominantly what is
leaving them in temporary accommodation
for longer um
cost suitability and lack of permanent
accommodation which is why we've had a
significant increase in our temporary
accommodation costs
um
we have to accept it as a main housing
Duty and we have a legal duty to keep
them in temporary accommodation and to
cure permanent accommodation and as
you'll see from the flow chart that Duty
only ends once we've secured a property
in either a social housing property or
an acceptable
property
within their uh which meets their their
requirements effectively
um
that duty is discharged if we find a
permanent secure accommodation
um it's also discharged if they uh
deliberately do an actual remission
which uh would happen a victim from a
property such as non-payment and rent
and when we say non-payment of rent
that's when we wouldn't look to
discharge if it's an affordability
matter but if they're when is it within
their price range
um after the assessment being undertaken
and they haven't paid it then that would
be
um a Act of intentionally homeless or
sometimes we do have
um difficulties when they cause damage
to the property or antisocial behavior
um I'm happy to take questions on it but
effectively in summary that that's our
um of Duty and it's fairly extensive as
as you can see
there you are you've got it you all talk
about it none of you got me control over
it would you like to know what's
happening quite rightly
and they're accused
hang up on the ball of them evening wear
it tends to be my view to it
no one wishing to comment it is for
noting
well I guess we're not here
thank you Stacy
now we do move on to item 13.
um
there's plenty of curiosity Sean I'm
wondering
about the
it Festival which is scheduled to take
place in April 2022 when the report was
written yeah
uh what when this report was written
yeah yeah it was written in uh well only
a couple of weeks ago
thank you so uh a very brief report in
front of you uh I I remember first
talking to uh Community Resources
committee about this Market Covenant in
2012 uh because we hadn't been aware of
his existence before that but it's a
covenant that was established to protect
the probability of benefit paneer Market
exactly extensively it stipulates that
within a six mile radius of bideford the
council needs to approve of markets
um last year we adopted our road to
recovery document which is around uh
banks are back in the covid pandemic uh
one of the express actions in that
document was that we would encourage
such markets wherever possible to drive
football into our town centers
um and sort of increase the tourism
Opera of the area and one of the things
that's cropped up is that you know
people are starting now Chris and his
team right there
um beavering away trying to make these
things these opportunities available to
people people are starting to get
interested in it and we're likely get
several applications and therefore every
single one would need to come back to
Committee in that report that we brought
last year you delegated authority to
approve those markets for 12 months to
the chief executive and what this report
recommends is that you just continue
with that delegation but without the
time limitation thank you chair
it's pretty straightforward I can't help
thinking will someone propose it please
I can't salute James or councilor
Brenton secondly he wants to speak right
you should speak yes thank you
well on the recommendation
I would put an addendum the end of it
but after a bit of her annual Market has
proved unviable and consultation with
the tan mayor these charges were put in
place for a good reason
that was to uh
look after the interests of return I
mean after all I could have pretend took
over at the uh the market from storage
because she well knows a pretty poor
State and was about to be handed over to
a private company which within six
months one must this Council would have
been numbered then with a large listed
building I wouldn't know what to do with
it because he didn't run the market very
well indeed at all before that so um I
think the market is still got potential
there it still needs using and I think
some organizations don't look at it
first before they go off to find some
alternative base
so um I don't see any problems of having
that identical there
is deals to be done with the market but
really
you make a proposal have you got a
second there
or either I'll try
and counselor James has made a proposal
because he got a second there
we've all gone to sleep
counselor Hudson I'm not seconding
anybody I just need some clarification
and I don't know whether I'm being
incredibly dense because it's quite
accessible uh but where it says under
three on page 64. it is not legal to
operate a market and benefit Northern
Ireland or whisper time or other
communities within a six mile radius
we've had markets going on all over the
place we've had markets in Africa uh
that have been
um requests for Market stalls I know
there hasn't come to fruition yet but
it's best interest in Westwood home
um does this uh recommendation
uh I know it's delegating authority to
the chief executive
uh would the chief executive say no
Ecuador Westwood home uh Northern I
don't know
are within these six miles so I don't
know you can't have a market what what
happens sorry to the big sheep Market
that's on at the moment on Saturday yeah
this is obviously an issue for hundreds
of years
um and some markets have have uh
consents that date back a long time
recent markets I don't know about the
big cheaper there must have been some
previous consent for that if not I guess
if it's operating without consent
um in recent markets uh have been
operated under the delegated authority
of the chief execas was delegated last
time and in previous years I've brought
reports back to committee Arsenal for
authority to set up a license for a
marketing
but I've been on the council three years
and I don't think I've ever
no attended a meeting we're sorry Mr
chairman but I've never attended a
meeting where we've been asked to
authorized because they're not that
frequent chair so I'm sorry for Jeff
what you have is uh in three years we
didn't have any true covid for instance
um Jubilee square is a space where you
have already given consent for markets
to happen there's a minute that states
that they can happen there and Bedford
King uh What uh what we're finding now
is that actually people want to do
markets so what we're trying to do is
get ahead of the game here instead of
having to bring a report back to you
every single time somebody comes to us
with a request we're just going to uh
we're asking for delegation and that's
because we anticipate the frequency of
request is going to increase
Clemson Haynes I think Joe yeah
um well my experience is that Ward
members as a war member in Africa I was
a consulted by the appropriate officer
they don't want to use to do with the
Fresh Food Market on the keynote
um so I mean it might be an idea for one
of your one of the committee members to
suggest that
uh chief executive makes a decision in
consultation with board members possible
and I've definitely been to a meeting
whereby this has come up before so um
it's not an evening and I'm just going
to ask Steve what is the sort of
protocol you go by and to assess whether
there's any chance of using anywhere
um
so ordinary something that come from
economic development team so usually
through Christopher or Thursday they've
been contacted uh as indicated in this
one came out in April 23 which is just
April 22 in the in the pack
um so they'll work with the
applicant to consider that the take both
thing they want and then as it comes to
him said we'll contact the awards member
to ensure there's no conflict there and
equally contact so our property to you
to make sure there's no conflict in
terms of where the things have been
Associated and we've had is where
there's been health and safety concerns
as they were in Appleton so all of those
things are taken into account
okay councilor Locke
yeah I mean I would like to add a
another sentence in the recommendation
for a period of five years because if
you're in that five-year period the
scheme doesn't work then you've always
got that chance to change it again
come to the Lord
again wouldn't that would be counselor
who made the proposal amended to include
the words that means consultation with
board member if he's happy to do that I
would be happy to second
yeah I understood that was something in
any way to the property
and yeah
is there a secondary to council and
locks proposed amendment yeah it was
three years
I would have thought three was better
because you're not committing a council
you know with election times
three years and three years but you had
another proposal counselor
it seems a lot of work over some of the
central openings
right take it forward as written
but it's to be for three years
and
all kinds of consultation with Ward
members
have we got that
okay let's try it through the vote those
in favor please show sorry
I I gotta say it yeah
the counseling rules one two three four
five six seven eight nine
that's unanimous
okay
Now we move all my secret to agenda item
14.
and these sold disposal of part of the
sports grain Kingsley Road
right
um the the only issue of the sports
ground here in Biddeford are the
long-running the long-running Cyber
we'll talk those of you are familiar
with
um and had to look at
um whether to Grant a bit of a football
club
um a at least of 25 years uh they
currently occupy Sports ground under
their 20 year license uh this excludes
The Robin's Nest uh so they hold a just
a long-term ground lease on the land for
the Robin's Nest and Robin's Nest is
exactly their building
um they would like a lease as that will
enable them to approach bodies such as
Sports England for funding in essence
the license doesn't give them sufficient
security to allow them to secure funding
so that is really what what they're
looking for for Elise
um it's been a long run cyber uh over
the years I understand there have been
negotiations that really have got
anywhere I think primarily due to their
insistence of some sort of security of
Kenya either 25 years where there was
security tennis or contractual right to
renew the lease or even a longer lease
um and this is this is not even though
it's primarily not really Council policy
to Grant leases along with 25 years in
general primarily it's it's not in the
council's gift because the lands affect
the under the auspices of fields and
trust and they will not Grant uh such
leases
so
um and and it is important that we have
fields and Trust been sent
um because the council has agreed as it
states here that it will allow the land
to be used with perpetuity as a playing
field for the benefit of the public so
benefit AFC do not have salt rights on
this land we have to think about
um rights to the public and Community
use and that's what we're addressing
here by big so
um well I think probably the hottest
earlier we had a meeting with them and
um uh they finally saw sense and said we
understand uh that
um you cannot grant us the security that
we would like we would agree to a
25-year lease without security tell you
so we then 90 rounds and some terms
which we've got down here principal
terms
um are your 25 year lease rent of a
nominal pound uh it will hand over the
repair and maintenance obligation for
the club and I'm sure that um if if my
uh the rest of my team and also Richard
haste uh was here he would be uh he
would be smiling from uh why air
together at this point
um the uh use
um so the probability would be playing
fields for uh for the use of benefit air
C but also requiring the facilities to
be made available for uh for public use
so that will be included within uh the
lease
um we have agreed with them that uh all
income that they receive will be
reinvested in the facilities
um and just quickly on the demise
um to clarify current demise of their
license includes the skatepark it won't
include that area or the van to the to
the north
um my question why we are going to give
it to them for a pound well firstly
um this actually costs the council
um quite a lot of money every year at
the moment
um perhaps a little hard to quantify
because the current charging mechanism
is is slightly opaque there's a
mechanism an unsatisfactory mechanism in
the current license agreement as to how
much is charged and it's based around
how much the council spends on
maintenance the number of matches that
Biddeford played there or to be declared
to make way there and so for uh
um the current year the license fee is
is only just under two and a half
thousand pounds that they pay to the
council
um now we do benefit from the income
from the three telecoms leases at the
moment those will if the lease goes
through to the to the football club
those will significantly reduce and they
will inherit those uh those leases so
you can see
um that uh the outgoings that council is
forced to spend on maintenance and
grounds maintenance in particular
um bar exceeds the the income so by
granting them a lease for a pound we
would actually be significant
financially better off
than we are at present
um some people have said well what we
shouldn't there be at least some form of
rent uh I think we feel that actually
that would just detract from their
ability so that would just be money they
would be giving to us rather the money
that would be going back into the
facilities I think as and when they if
they take on the lease if members
approve this idea
um they will understand the reality of
the costs and they will actually need
all the money that they can get to keep
those facilities going and to improve
them
um so we're really here to uh give your
support to that we hope
um and also to allow an approach to
bills and trusts to be made
um as uh as has to be done they will
have to give their Authority for this
needs to be granted
um and one of the
the other part of it is is the community
use and how that is going to be governed
because obviously if we Grant these
together it'd be very easy for them to
say thank you we've got our leads for
all the current league football and how
are we we as a council control what uh
Community use they provide as we are
mandated to provide so that
Community use and all the conditions
around that probably don't sit well in a
lease so a service level agreement will
sit alongside that and that was that
requirement packs if you've had a chance
to read that
um that great
um and I think that will enable the
council to monitor uh benefits of
football club's approach to the
community use the intention is that
there will be a Review Committee which
will comprise the club by officers from
from the council and board member
representation as well which would meet
annually to review how things have gone
in the previous year take into account
um any changes in public use that uh
maybe may be needed as time goes on
um and it could also act as a as a bit
of a check on how the club is
maintaining the facilities and the
financial side as well
um so I think that really um summarizes
this
and
thank you Jim any questions all right
thank you Nick
um this is a problem that my 20 odd
years of Torrance Council has been
existing this Council has spent a
fortune subsidizing bit of football club
I would like to move this recommendation
from the chair on the basis that we are
getting rid of an awful lot of
liabilities
probably more of them actually set out
on the agenda because the rent on the
mobile phone mass is going to largely
disappear under the new legislation
uh costs of mowing the pictures which
we've done for years
disappearing It's a Wonderful move
Whoever has negotiated this one from
torrington's point of view has done a
wonderful job in my book am I moving
into the chair I'll second actually then
Captain oddsson yeah I was going to
Second subject to just again on the
devil's in the details this uh Review
Committee is part of the SLA uh what
teeth do they have for non-compliance
with uh maintenance because this I
notice of fully repairing these and
having stopped around a bit of a
football ground there's quite a lot of
work that needs to be undertaken and
done and
I would like to be assured that those
obligations are honored and we have the
capacity
to insist because I know
and this is no condemnation of officers
but we've talked about the mess down at
the dealership uh Bishop we've talked
about failure to enforce conditions on
other schemes that we've had do we have
uh the resources to be able to make sure
that that football ban is maintained to
the highest safety standards for uh
football fans to be able to use it
so just to address your first point
about with the Review Committee um have
any ability to enforce maintenance
repair
um it we haven't really gone into any
detail as to what the Review Committee
will be responsible for
um it could be included that they would
have some input but I think it would
really be the least Clauses that would
uh by the the primary
ability for the council to enforce to
enforce preparing governments in the
list
yes so there must be sorry can I just
responding again it's this this uh
dependence on a very clearly defined and
specific lease with the powers to
actually
enforce and the ability to enforce that
is critical in any of these Arrangements
I think I quite agree with councilor
Hicks
uh this uh this
um Club has across the council a lot of
money I'd like to see this go forward
but again the devil's in the detail and
I really do think we should be very
mindful to that
that's what we pay our officers for
they'll sort out whether it's put and
keep or maintain in respect of the
repairs within the lease whether there's
a sentiment condition whether it needs
one that's the officer job and I'm sure
we can rely on them to do it right
the only question I've got I've been
done this deal with Benefits football
club what about Turin
sure I think that'll be subject at a
different report
right okay put this under the boat those
in favor of please show
that's you know us thank you
no well
I think it's better for our next
and the chair just seem to be bringing
you problems to resolve today
um so chloroform borrow Farm is the
average land up next to uh torridge pool
in Northern it's owned by Northern Town
Council and leased to the football club
and all lions uh it used to belong to
tourist District Council until 2009 when
it was transferred the transfer
documentation is
records so when that transfer occurred
uh we as a council placed covenants
restricted covenants on the land to make
sure that it stayed as public open space
it's been brought to our attention and
we've discussed with Northern tampons
the erection of a fence around the
football pitch now what we're not making
a judgment here are it is whether the
fence is intended to solve a problem
it's undoubtedly interactive with
Goodwill to solve adult filing and
social behavior issues that are being
found on the page but what that fence
does do is in his access free and easy
access if you like by the public to
football pitch
that opinion has been confirmed by
fields and trust and we believe that the
fencing its current form of the local
gate is is actually a breach of Covenant
so I've tried to outline the main issues
in the report for you we think there are
a number of options that are available
to Northern South Council those options
include taking the fence down obviously
there's nothing there's no problems
there from our point of view there's no
problems from fields and Trust point of
view but there is a management issue
that would need to be resolved well
uh you could leave the fencing up uh but
the gate unlocked and again fusing trust
have indicated verbally but not in any
written form yet but they would be happy
with that Arrangement so I'll go so
Would we that means public open spaces
um mandate is still preserved
um or Northern could apply to field and
Trust uh to leave the fence in lockable
gate
um
they've sort of done that in an informal
manner to date an indication has been
that that wouldn't be approved so so
that kind of leads us on to the
recommendations
uh so it's recommended to you that if an
application to building trust or offense
with lockable gains with suitable
Community Arrangement Community Access
right wider than just the pitch
leaseholder is approved that the council
would defer to the fields and Trust
decision and offer consent pressured so
at that point we would no longer
consider a breach of government if field
interests do not consent to the fence
and the local Gates and the council
should then the councils can formally
request that Northern Town Council
either remove the lock on the gate to
ensure unrestricted access to the field
or remove the fence and gate in its
entirety and the intention of these
recommendations is to ensure that the
entirety of the transferred land that
Borough Farm remains appropriately
managed public open space so it's over
to you thank you
all right cancel it out and I just asked
um how high is that it's three three
meters high from I think it was just I
think it's three meters it didn't
require planning because it was done
under the northern's Community
Development right okay well it would
normally be Terminator no I think this
uh I think it was three uh in certain
circumstances and I think it's three
hmm
right councilor bright yeah because
there's a confirmation of where the
fence is on that diagram it's a random
footballer or just the square in the
middle yeah the square in the middle is
a little bit it roughly follows the that
area with a with an appropriate runoff
not the entire no not until one
councilor laws
[Music]
um none of the counselors I had in the
right were aware of the respective
Covenant ontology Department
failed to recognize that there was one
although it was just in 2009 it's a
transfer took place
so agreement was kind of was made with
the football club that they could apply
for a grant
to uh
to arrest the banks
um which they went ahead and did
Northern joined and became a joint
applicant
but I must say at this stage I and I
know a lot of the chances are unhappy
with this situation we have to come to
an agreement that feels then trust we
must mandatory must be within my
personal
Banks but again it's just become
unlocked they can be front loaded I mean
all sorts of things but basically leave
the best
thank you
councilor Hurley thank you chair I'd
seem to agree with that my my soul
screens happened same as that according
to move in the events has been put down
for a reason maybe it's not dogs failing
I don't know which is a mayor something
down we're all up and down the country
there
um and if the gate is spring-loaded
what's wrong loaded that's good as well
but Mr gate will be closed if that's the
loose dogs effectively flying in our
place so I'll I'll go along with my new
profession it is take the rock away
okay
um
councilor lock is the pictures on a
regular basis
[Music]
yeah very much so it's uh they they
operate senior teams and junior teams
I'm not sure whether we've got the
latest thing but
um there's a lot of use on that picture
so they've got dug out on the picture
yeah there's Doug ocean changing
facilities there
I'm just not sure and though as far as
they're blocking the gates in the fence
that that can be done at dusk and not
again in the morning
that happens on the sports ground in
Biddeford
so it's locked up at night
and you don't want people going in there
tonight
cancel the laws yeah I I must come back
on that regiment access to the public
I'm thinking of children here and young
people to arrive at a have a kicker bag
in the summer it's seven or eight at
night you're never going to employ
offices to become at random transgender
billions in trust saying unknowns public
and and what happens in
in benefit I don't like
[Music]
um
it's transferred into that privility
from the car park that turretch I was
down near the Rugby Club in Whitaker so
this is the King George's epitome
it's always the sports around invisible
King George a big field now if that's
locked up at the moment which you know
is the support
why can't we look this way but now once
decibels we hire Torres higher security
companies to go around and look up at
Westfield again I'm sure we've been
known 10 Council can arrange that they
get lots of consent and once adjustable
so so chair that that's wrapped up I
think in the first paragraph of the
recommendation but if an application to
people's interest for a Bets with a
lockable gate with arrangements for
Community Access wider than just the
pitch lease out there is approved then
we as a council would agree that fields
and trustive agreeds there's no problem
that's the lock on the gate and the
Locking of that gate that is the is the
restriction on public open space so it
feels interests were happy with that I
think as a council we'd recommend it we
you should be as well
but
yes the the recommendation is fairly
lengthy but actually when you analyze it
it's allowing for all eventualities
turned upon others
I think I'll propose it from the chair
as written
is there a second it's about yes I have
a second candidate
any other proposals
on it to the vote those in favor please
show
okay one two three four five six seven
eight nine
that's unanimous thank you Jack
Now we move on to
uh
right yes we're going to go into the
park too can we have the nomination to
go and talk to councilor James councilor
Hobson and we take about all in favor of
going into part two
that is unanimous
so we're now in part two